so it looks like we have some angry cats
on our hands
yeah
yeah they they seem angry
and what we want to do is think about
how can we separate these angry cats
because the only thing worse than an
angry cat is 12 of them coordinating
potentially to take over the world
and so what we're going to think about
is can we divide these 12 angry cats
into equal groups and just for the sake
of this video let's say we want to
divide them into three equal groups how
could we do that
well let me see if i can do it let's see
maybe this is one
group right over here
maybe
this is another group
right over there and then this is
another group are those three equal
groups
well see this top group has four this
group has three and this one has five so
no these aren't three equal groups so
that won't work it has to be not just
three groups three equal groups
so let me see if i can do something
different i could have these four in a
group
and then i could have these four in a
group i think this is going to work out
this time
and then i could have these four
in a group
and as i just said out loud all of these
groups have exactly four angry cats in
them which is a little bit more
manageable and so this works out i have
just divided the 12 into three equal
groups and how many cats are in each of
those equal groups well we can see very
clearly that there are four cats in each
of those equal groups so the way to
think about division in this example is
you started with 12 and you divided into
three
equal
three equal groups
and we ended up with four cats
four cats
per
group
now what if we wanted to interpret it
slightly differently so let's bring in
12 more angry cats which is always a
dangerous thing to do but we're doing it
for the sake of learning so it's worth
it
meow
yep more angry cats
and now let's imagine 12 divided by 3 12
divided by
3 but this time we're not going to think
about the 3 as 3 equal groups we're
going to think about it as 12 divided
into groups of three
so groups
groups of three so each of the equal
groups will have three in them and so
then that's going to tell us how many
equal groups we were able to have so
let's do that let's create groups of
three
so
let's see that's a group of three angry
cats right over there
this is another group of three angry
cats
this is a group of three angry cats
and then this is a group of three angry
cats
so how many equal groups of three angry
cats do i have well i have one
two
three and four equal groups so if i want
to take 12 egg cats and divide them into
groups of three i end up with four
equal
four equal groups
so there you have it there's two
different ways that we can imagine
division
and the same exact division expression
12 divided by three you could view it as
12 being divided into three equal groups
and then the the answer
would be how many things per group or
you could say hey 12 divided into groups
of three and then that would end up with
four equal groups